bueno en la condena que ha realizado
boric que como sabemos es un presidente
del presidente más joven de la historia
de chile con 35 años y que está
conectado con la actualidad a pesar de
encontrarse en este momento en
vacaciones vía twitter es muy similar a
la misma reacción que ha tenido el
presidente del gobierno chileno
sebastián piñera quien también ha
condenado la invasión a ucrania así como
ha llamado a rusia a respetar la
convención de ginebra y el derecho
internacional en este caso vemos que se
trata de una política de estado que va
más allá de los colores políticos hay
unanimidad en el pueblo chileno que
también se levanta en el día de hoy
conmocionado por las noticias que se ven
que llegan desde ucrania aunque es
verdad que el chileno tiene una relación
especialmente cercana con rusia si la
tiene con china que podría ser uno de
los aliados de rusia en esta en este
conflicto y también con eeuu eso lo
pondría a chile en una situación más
compleja pero sí que vemos que el
presidente electo gabriel boric y en
este caso se alinea también con la misma
la misma postura política que plantea el
actual presidente sebastián piñera una
política de estado entonces que
transciende los colores políticos